there's an industry around everything
right so when my wife was pregnant we
got talked into having a doula come to
the house assurance now its doula if for
those of you are not in the know and
kelvis up in california a doula is
essentially a birth coach someone who
helps you with you know get ready for
your birth and helps you with exercises
and movement and this woman who I
started laughing you know me because I
get the girl is and she was like baby
wants to feel you Moo oh my who and she
I swear to God at one point my wife and
I was sitting there and she got up put
her hands on the wall and began to move
her ass think of a stripper think of the
[ __ ] stripper you've ever met and
she was not a bad-looking woman and my
wife was popping and this woman had I
was like you're clearly trying to bang
both of us you have a fetish area for
pregnant women right now I was like
honey using that you hit this one out
let me make sure everything's all right
over here if you want that newly pair
train ran on it oh she wanted a little
new parent dick yeah and she was just
rubbing her ass in the air like that and
swirling and I looked at my wife I go
you gotta be kidding me right as I said
I started a laugh be at the fight that's
what the deal were negotiating right now
you'll be at the fight now working that
whole week now is there a shot to bring
you I know bro I know I mean I know no
I'm just saying I know now listen what
raycast for seven pickins got turned
down but I'm sure I can send your resume
and see what happens you know what it
did can I be honest with you I never
thought you'd betray me yeah it's
amazing how it is a lose I will try my
dad I forgot about all braai thanks for
the memories if just call me memories
from now on I kill me Olmo memories
old man you met memory lane a boy I'll
videotape it on my phone phone phone
I'll FaceTime you immensely it's like
you're sitting next well tickets are
like I think wings had tickets are a
million dollars I don't know the once
they go into the public it won't be
meaning to the rest like industry but I
think 10,000 you see on your lap now
faced on you man
although I do my saying you see and say
no say something I'll bring you the like
linear that they give us all right
thanks man your lanyard lanyards it's a
little pretty thanks buddy
oh hey good news bad news bad news is I
can't get you the fight good news is
somebody's bringing you back I had no
land you got your hat and a nice whoa
did you did you expect any of this like
officer you've worked some big fights
before man and you know I think everyone
knew the magnitude of this site was
going to be big but you know I said on
my show last Friday when I came back I
thought I I could even picture it being
this big it was unbelievable man
I mean I'll tell you what when I
expected to be big but you don't really
know the magnitude you don't really
understand the language will happen to
you to me so far this has been bigger
than Mayweather Pacquiao and Mabel
attack here was the biggest ever work to
him so and for me this has been bigger
than that so far I also worked a very
big fighter when you can earlier this
year of the into the actual environment
Klitschko but because I was on this side
of the pond I didn't get the full
build-up anticipation like I may have if
I was over in the UK you know I mean
that would have also made to fight a
soul a stadium and it was an incredibly
intense fight this one because it's
happening on this side of the pond I'm
getting all the build-up and I'm getting
all the anticipation from here I'm
saying and and competitors am able to
Pacquiao but so far this has been bit a
bigger deal and Mayweather Pacquiao from
even and I really I think the the soul
the soul miracle of that goes to Conor
McGregor but that he's been this
polarizing figure I can match up to
Floyd Mayweather and every single press
conference match him for every single
quote even surpassing the times he's
very witty very astute and it's aw it's
made for some really are rollicking
exchanges and volley really you look
love if Bret win that nany and this all
iy this is in front of wifey Ossipee
ytc this [ __ ] daddy bro what he
teaches me she watched him he goes why
do I have women hire really hot I said
to my wife
you're whatever a medium your wife goes
Oh Brian I was like why would you hire
this set you up with her she could have
won Miss Sweden she was
I was reading here your wife is probably
very confident she's very confident but
I wonder if she wants to end up like
them I couldn't do a damn thing so I was
like bro this is your back wait that you
smell funny if she was setting him up
just for like she wants to get with her
that's a great hey lady great house
great angle we get our Swartz Degas I'm
nothing like we dish model oh my god so
hot she was 10 of God's like what she's
a decent man T - Brian goes I thought
myself checking my hair before she would
come in I'd be like is this shirt I was
like alright that's it
get rid her right now I don't want to
remind her if she was going back to
Sweden anyway otherwise it would have
been you know stone cold I remember
trying to set I was like bro I got the I
mean this is Miami hugging our humps
weird eyes you want ya crooked eye and
are just so horny like you know like
they'll they'll [ __ ] you know however so
she doesn't even have to be that hot
look at all this worst thing is like
Zack [ __ ] it
yeah at a kid with a beautiful kid -
really oh yeah it was like the the
straight-up Nate like nanny nanny alike
yeah why do you think men are so horny
testosterone spread our sea life our
vacation once we get this we got to
spread a sheet over here if you're an
alpha male like me an apex alpha is an
apex you want a gift you want to give
the world with your seed with your heavy
load